I'd like to welcome you to the third
Communications Forum event of the term
an event we're co-sponsoring with the
the the night science journalism
fellowship program and the head of that
program my collaborator in presenting
this event today and in getting Jay
Rosen to come and address us uh will
speak after me and give some additional
brief remarks and introduce our
panelists I'm David thorburn the
director of the MIT Communications Forum
I'd like to say two things uh uh uh
as preliminary to our to our event today
the first is to announce our final event
of the term which will take place on
Friday May 4th it's a forum titled
electronic literature and future books
uh and it runs from 5: to 7 p.m. in BTO
theater in the media lab uh that event
will be the culmination of a day long
also open to the public free Symposium
on uh the on the future of the book and
on the the ways in which the book is
being transformed the title of the whole
conference is something like Unbound the
book in the digital age and you're all
invited of course to attend any of those
sessions and I especially urge that you
consider attending the final conference
at which Katherine hailes from duke Nick
monford of MIT and Rita Ry from the
University of California Santa Barbara
will be the
panelists I also want to uh uh just
before I introduce my colleague Phil
hiltz uh i' like to I'd like to uh
indicate to you or remind those of you
who don't know who know this and to uh
inform those of you who I inform those
of you who don't know this and remind
those of you who do uh that the
communications Forum uh could be said to
have as a continuing theme a kind of
subtext that runs through many many of
our events the role of Journalism in the
Modern Age and especially the problem
that Phil Rosen and Ethan will be
addressing today the problems having to
do with the Mig ation of our uh of the
whole apparatus of print culture into
digital formats it's an immensely
complex problem problem as I'm sure all
of you are aware and has a particular
salience in a democracy when we consider
what's happening to journalism and I so
I urge you to think about this forum in
the context of so many others that we've
held and I'd even urge you to go go to
The Forum website where the last 15
years of our activities are archived
very extensively in including
video and audio transcripts of every
event and as well as as well as text
summaries and summaries and other other
kinds of transcripts a little less
dramatic are available going back as
much as 25 years uh with that said I'd
like to introduce my colleague Phil
hiltz the director of the night uh uh
journalism prog uh science writing
program at MIT to continue the
introduction thanks um just just want to
give you a little bit of background on
our
guests um Ethan Zuckerman is the
director of the center for civic media
at MIT uh principal research scientist
at the MIT media lab um his research
includes the use of technology for
International Development and the use of
New Media te Technologies by activists
uh his uh main claim to fame at least as
far as I'm concerned is global voices a
community of bloggers that is uh
worldwide and uh going strong you can
find his blog at Ethan Zuckerman
dcom um J Ro Rosen is has been a on the
faculty at NYU for 25 years uh he's the
author of press think blog about
journalism and its ordeals um he's also
the author of the book what are
journalist
for um and he's the uh director of a a
new project at NYU called U Studio 20 uh
let me read you uh one paragraph the
beginning of U the blog or the
information on the NYU site the studio20
concentration at NYU offers Master's
level instruction with a focus on
Innovation and adapting journalism to
the web the curriculum emphasizes
project-based learning students faculty
and visiting Talent work on editorial
and web development projects together
typically with Media Partners who
themselves need to find new approaches
or face problems in succeed in
succeeding
online by participating in these
projects and later running their own
students learn to Grapple with all the
factors that go into updating journalism
for the web era which seems to be kind
of the center of the topics that we're
all dealing with now this conversation
about the crisis in journalism has been
going on for some years now uh we still
have daily some notes of alarm out there
and then we have this other thing the
notes of frustration and even bored with
the fact that we're going on and on with
this conversation and not sure we're
getting
anywhere um which is the reason why we
have these two here now because um Jay
Rosen and Ethan Zuckerman have been uh
the voices out there that have U
penetrating cogent things to say about
these topics preserving the core of
Journalism while moving it into um the
web so um with that uh Jay you want to
start thank you very much
um and thank all of you for coming
it's super exciting for me to be at MIT
which is an institution I admire so much
um and to see people um who I know here
and and a whole bunch that I've probably
never met um adapting journalism to the
web is something I've been writing and
thinking and talking about
for I think eight
years um so I want to start with
something I haven't said yet
um as a way of of um of of
opening one way to have uh a new idea an
underappreciated method of generating
Insight is to take things that are
closely related to one another and
sometimes confused for one
another and pull them
apart so that there's new space
opened between and among them
and one of my intellectual Heroes uh
Hannah arent used to do this constantly
in her work she was a political
philosopher great historian of
totalitarianism and she would take these
pairs of terms that are very kind of
close and say actually these are totally
different so she'd say um like U labor
and
work actually these don't have anything
to do with one another but let me tell
you what labor is because that's
completely different than work right and
by separating these two terms you now
you could like think a new with them
another one my favorite one uh of hers
is a distinction that she Drew between
action and
behavior said wait a minute these two
things are not the
same behavior is when we lose ourselves
in routines when you do the predictable
thing
action is when we set out on something
new so that's interesting now you can
now you can use those terms now you can
play around with it so what I thought I
would do by way of beginning is take
some things that have been too closely
associated with one another that kind of
overlap or they're confused for one
another and pull them
apart so the first thing we need to
think about when we think about adap
adapting journalism to the
web is the practice of Journalism so
that's one thing the practice of
Journalism and today to get ahead of our
story a little bit we have professionals
practicing journalism and we have
amateurs practicing journalism and we
have something that I'm really
interested in which is proam journalism
right the practice is what people do
when they're doing journalism
it's
active but that's different than the
second thing I want to talk about which
is the underlying media system that the
practice runs
on that's different right the underlying
media system in the 1950s and 60s was
mass circulation newspapers news
magazines and television stations on
some radio right that's a media system
it's used for more than just
journalism so the media system is the
way that we produce information
distribute it connect people to it in
society as a
whole that's different than the practice
of
Journalism the third thing that we
should be able to pull
apart is the institution of the press
the institution of the press which is
actually what I've studied for my entire
career the press as an
institution is first of all different
from country to
Country the reason it's different from
country to country is that it's very
powerfully a product of
law if you don't have law establishing
freedom of the press you don't have any
press you might have journalism you
might have a media system but you don't
have a press because everything that
happens is just a um pale reflection of
politics so until you have a public
sphere until you have a free press until
you have
legal um system that secures the rights
of a free press you can't have a press
so each press is
different for example in
Holland
broadcasting and news was for a very
long time organized around what the
Dutch called the pillars of society
there was a
Catholic Channel there was a Protestant
Channel there was like a Social Democrat
Channel there was a conservative Channel
and that's how the entire system was
organized because that's the way the
Dutch did it um so the institution of
the press includes the laws that make it
possible to practice journalism it
includes not really companies so much
as journalistic cultures inside the
those companies like there's a there's
kind of like a wing of the press in the
New York Times building but it's not
everything at the New York Times it's
the journalists and the people who
support the journalists so it's
institutions it's professional
associations like the American Society
of newspaper editors which dates from
the
1920s and which President Obama spoke to
this week if you saw that and then
Romney spoke to that them the next day
so professional associations
professional
codes um
law uh and the institution of the press
includes what I call and named my blog
press think meaning the ideas that a
given press
has about the right way to practice
journalism just half an hour ago Ethan
and I and I in his class were talking
about how British journalists don't
think it's rude at all to interrupt
somebody who's not answering the
question and say
answer the question what is this right
whereas in America you don't do that
right so those are different ideas about
how
so if we take these things the practice
of
Journalism just how people do it the
underlying media
system that journalism runs
on the institution of the press we
realize they're
different now we
have uh a better way of asking our
question well how is journalism adapting
to the web
because the changes that Phil referred
to in introduction this introducing this
event the enormous transformation that's
undergone in journalism
since it's hard to say exactly when
since but let's say 1995 when I think
the web first made it on to the cover of
Time Magazine
um are driven by one of those three
things changes in the underlying media
system from a basically
broadcast
dominated system to something much
different
today then
caused and influenced and made possible
lots of changes in the practice of
Journalism and then those changes in
practice are forcing the institution of
the press to
change and so it's the middle term the
media system that's changing the
most it's disrupting the practice of
Journalism and it's forcing the
institution uh of the press to change
now just to continue with this
tripartite system a little bit I have
different names for the people on the
receiving end of these three things and
that's also something that I've studied
my whole career I approached the Press
by starting with the people on the
receiving end rather than starting with
professional
journalists so the people on the
receiving end in the practice of
Journalism I think we should call them
the
users that's who they are that's my
they're the users it's the most active
alive concept that I can think of uh for
the people who we do the practice for we
do PR we practice journalism for people
who have to put it to some use so we
call them the users the people on the
receiving end of the media
system I think we should probably call
those people the victims no we we should
prob prob we call those people the
audience
or the people formerly known as the
audience which was the blog post I wrote
in
2006 because the people Formerly Known
the as the audience refers to the fact
that the people on the receiving end of
the media system can do a lot more than
they used to be able to do right so we
can't just call them the audience
anymore the people on the receiving end
of the
press are the public the press and the
public go together they really are two
different ways of naming the same
thing um and that's what I did my
dissertation about in 1986 is the public
as the thing on the receiving end uh of
the press so the changes started in that
in that middle term there right and
they're cascading through the sort of
the rest of the
Contraption now I want to say one more
word about about that middle term when I
teach students about the difference the
web is make or when I talk to
journalists about
it I try to start with something that's
very Elusive and and and especially to
people who are um are part of Phil's
generation or David's generation is is
kind of dissolved uh into their own
practices and that is
the image of the people out there that
the media system prior to the internet
built up in the minds of of journalists
so the the way I try to get at this is
by
showing a clip of a scene that probably
most of you know from the movie network
you know Network and there's a very
famous scene in that movie where um
where the crazed Anchor Man Howard
Beal uh has kind of losing his mind
but he's getting
ratings so they keep him on the air and
one day he literally rises from his
anchor man's desk and stares into the
camera and tells the people out there
that he wants them to get up from their
television sets and go to the windows
and open the windows and shout out to
the world I'm mad as hell and I'm not
going to take it anymore right which
later became like a rallying cry for the
tea party and you know like 30 years
later 40 years later so so that's the
scene it's a great scene so one of my
favorite scenes in media movies
because um you never see that you never
see somebody on television telling you
stop watching television it's like the
one thing they never say um but what
what happens in that scene which I've
watched like hundreds of times but if
you think about what's going on in that
scene people
are um sitting there in their normal
State welcome they're they're sitting
there watching television in what was
the normal State for the audience to be
in for decade after decade and that is
in your private location whether it's
your living room watching TV or The
Breakfast Table with the newspaper or
your car listening to NPR right you're
in your private location
connected up to a big institution like
the network or in the case of the State
of the Union Address the presidency
right connected
up
receiving images
information talk and unable
to
transmit and not only that connected
vertically and disconnected
from everybody else right or
atomized now if you try what I try to
get people to do and thinking about
what's different about journalism is
actually visualize people that way not
one person it's easy to visualize one
person but a visualize a million people
in that condition right private location
connected
up silent and
inert ready to receive
disconnected from everybody
else that was my
childhood that's the first 20 years of
my life that's basically all I did I
went to school and I did
that why do you think I study media as
an act of
Revenge
so what I want you to appreciate is if
you can visualize the audience in that
fragmented one way disconnected atomized
State then you can realize how weird
that is it's just a strange interval in
human history that people were able to
be
combined in that way and for example
their attention could be aggregated and
sold as a
commodity strange weird Behavior so now
the underlying media system has changed
in a way
that it's just as easy to connect
horizontally to other people as it is to
connect vertically to the media the
president the company the right not it's
not that we don't connect vertically
anymore we do we still watch spectacles
we still we watch the Academy Awards
right which is Hollywood and it's stars
and it's you know you're just supposed
to bask in their Glory which we continue
to do and at the same time we're talking
horizontally to each other other because
the underlying media system permits that
okay so I wrote a piece about that in
2009 called audience atomization
overcome because I think that's the best
the the shortest description I could
give for that shift three words audience
atomization overcome so when we think
about adapting journalism to the web we
have to also talk about that because
that to me is really the heart of
of the change um okay
so that's all I wanted to say at the
beginning well that gives us a lot to
work with so so that was the idea Ju
Just So everyone sort of understands the
the format here our our goal is to sort
of have something of a of a structured
conversation and the structure means
that I'm going to control who has the
microphone uh but that's pretty much the
entirety of the structure that we have
for all of this Jay was going to come in
with a provocation and it's a helpful
one uh so I I'm gonna Now respond to
that in a question that's probably going
to take me roughly as long to get
through as it was for you to get through
that opening
statement I I'm heading there I promise
I'll I'll get there let let let me get
my sentences out and I'll so so uh a
after responding and asking a couple of
the questions that I want to ask we're
then going to open it up to the two
microphones we have on the floor and
that's what I meant by controlling the
mic was that this was going to be a
question and answer process so please
start thinking about what you want to be
asking and how you want to get in the
dialog but I want to push on a couple of
things from the model that you put
forward Jay so so what I think is very
helpful about this is in breaking apart
this sort of profound shift that
everyone's really been trying to deal
with for the last 10 years or so into
these three different categories you
give us a chance to confine some of the
existing debates that people have spent
an enormous amount of time on so for
instance if we take that the first shift
is a shift in the practice of Journalism
the idea that journalism for some period
of time was the province of a
professional class yes formally or
informally trained who engaged with a
certain particular code of ethics
generally paid to do so although there's
always been you know Community reporters
who are poorly paid at best um but a
strong distinction between professional
journalists and the people who they were
interacting with whether they were
eyewitnesses whether they were
commentators expert or inexpert in one
fashion or another one of the big shifts
that's happened in the space is that
that distinction has crumbled quite
sharply it is not that professional
journalists have gone away but we seem
to have gotten somewhat beyond the
Blogger versus
journalist topic that would have
dominated a gathering like this six or
seven years ago yes and there is at
least some steps towards acceptance that
people commit acts of Journalism some
people do them fairly often because it
is what they're paid to do some people
do it of often because it is their
passion and what they end up doing and
sometimes it is a person in a place who
gives a reliable account at the time and
attempts to verify it and is able to
commit that act of Journalism at the
time so there's one set of debates about
whose job is this who has the
opportunity to do this that we might be
able to put into one box there's a
second set of debates that we might
helpfully put in another box which we
might think of as medium debates and the
medium debates actually get pretty rich
and complicated because one set of them
quickly becomes Financial in a world
where you have broadcast control as you
said what you really have is the ability
to aggregate attention we're going to
give you the Morning News via paper
which suggests that some large fraction
of the literate adults in this city are
going to read these collected pieces of
paper which means we know where they're
spending their attention which is then a
monetizable capacity we know you're
going to be reading this paper you know
this department store doesn't
necessarily care any anything about the
current situation in Somalia but they do
care about the fact that you are turning
from page one to page two and have the
opportunity to see the ad at that point
but Best Buy never signed up to fund the
Baghdad Bureau as clay Shi says correct
right so we have the shift in business
models where it's becoming very very
clear that attention on the web is not
nearly as valuable eyeball to eyeball as
we thought it was on an offline world we
may have simply been wrong in an offline
world it's possible that advertising
just didn't work the way that we thought
it did but now that we have rationalized
the market and people can actually bid
for eyeballs one at a time on the web
that market has simply collapsed in
price we've gotten very very low very
very quickly second in the medium we
have
disaggregated so again as sheru has
pointed out if I wanted to pick up a
newspaper mostly because I wanted my
local news and I happen to stumble upon
that story in Somalia that is no longer
necessary because I am now reading local
news.com where my story about Somalia
would be incredibly inappropriate or in
my case I'm probably reading about
Somalia where the story about what's
going on in Roxberry might be incredibly
inappropriate that's called unbundling
so the unbundling argument the finance
argument the advertising argument and
then third as you were sort of going the
isolation argument which is to say that
in the past we were all encountering
media we might occasionally have written
to a letter to the editor which might
occasionally have gotten printed
but now some of us find ourselves in a
media experience where any broadcast
event is simultaneously event to connect
to respond back at the same time my my
recent experience of this was This
American Life retracting their mic da
story in a extremely powerful and
uncomfortable radio hour I which was
released and and I don't know if this
happened to you but as I was listening
to this that Friday night found myself
tweeting to the other you know several
hundred thousand people listening to it
at the same time and sort of having the
postmortem of how they were doing on the
piece as it was going out it's a very
different media experience then it all
goes one way and then it all comes
another way okay so let's put those in
those boxes now let's get to the one
where I'm less comfortable with where
you're going because I'm not sure what
this debate looks like which is this
debate about the institution of the
press so if the Press is a collection of
standards practices Norms institutions
and ways we think of doing our job MH
and if it's something that comes into
play because of the existence of a
particular legal structure a particular
um set of of practices that are in place
it seems like this is a deeply unsettled
space and a large number of the
arguments sort of still raging in this
space are B basically around the
question of is that idea that there is a
press and a public and that that press
is somehow following the set of
collective norms and rules and informing
a public does that make any sense
anymore right now here's where I want to
go with that one of the things you posit
I think maybe not
incorrectly is that op press is
something that happens particularly in a
free Society where it's protected by
rule of law where it's possible for
people to stand up and say I'm going to
speak freely and publish but now thanks
to those first two changes we're
starting to see a radical shift in that
environment right we are seeing people
attempting to influence a public whether
or not they consider themselves to be
part of the press or there whether or
not there is a free press so so let's
let's drill down on on something that
that you and I were both recently
reasonably fascinated by which is this
Mike Daisy case right so for for those
who don't know the details on this Mike
Daisy is a theatrical performer he does
more or less what we're doing he sits at
a table with a bottle of water and he
attempts to tell a compelling story to
keep a room like this entertained for
some period of time he's better at it
than we are so he gets larger crowds
they pay money for it but it's it's
fundamentally the same thing he's a
Storyteller who offers stories and
essays live on stage and he's been
telling a
story um that is quite in-depth and
detailed about the origin of Apple
products it's a story that talks about
the psychology of Steve Jobs it's a
story that talks about how products are
manufactured in in factories and the
center of the story in many ways is Mike
telling the story of his trip to Apple
factories in China and he tells us that
he stood outside Apple's Factory in
shenzen run by foxc con and interviewed
workers coming out who were 12 13 and 14
years old and after telling us about
interviewing
12-year-olds looks at us and says do you
think Apple really doesn't know do you
think a company that cares this much
about how its products are assembled
doesn't know very compelling story been
out there in the theatrical circuit for
months irog glass of This American Life
invited Daisy to come on his show and
tell this story tells the story it's one
of the best received episodes of the
radio show ever it then gets fact
checked it gets fact checked by someone
else in national public radio and it
turns out that basically none of Daisy's
facts are verifiable many of the stories
that he tells can be verified to other
journalists but there's no way to verify
it to stories that he saw and in fact in
factchecking they ask his translator his
translator says no we didn't see most of
those
things what I'm asking is that Daisy is
part of aou group of people who is
trying to influence the public right and
they are trying to influence the public
through creating media right and we're
now capable of creating media in any
number of different ways now Daisy is
very very clear that his job is not the
press and in fact when he apologizes for
all of this he apologizes for this
becoming journalism he apologizes for
this becoming press but what I want to
complicate with this idea of the press
is we now have many many different
actors trying to figure out how to have
this space to inform and influence
public right some people are standing up
and saying I'm a journalist some people
are saying I'm a proam journalist some
are saying I'm doing activist media some
are saying I'm simply an activist but
everyone is making some claim to
attention everyone is making some claim
to Authority and everyone is making some
claim to want to influence behavior in
one fashion or another right how do we
deal with this concept of the press when
you have everyone from Mike Daisy on
stage you have everyone from invisible
children with the coin 2012 video
producing information that they believe
you don't have you don't yet know about
the story in China you don't yet know
about the Lord's resistance are Army in
Northern Uganda they're making that
reporting claim but they're following a
very different set of rules and Norms
than the rules and Norms that you would
like to ascribe to a press how do we
start dealing with that right see I told
you I'd open up
space um because that's a very good
question um so I think a number of
things are going on there um first
because the media system has
changed lots of people can give us
information about the world and they do
and it comes to us in many different
forms and this is something that most
people recognize
now
um I
think to provide us with
journalism is a different thing it's a
subset of that larger
thing um now if we want to say okay so
when is it journalism which is a good
question much better question by the way
than who is a
journalist it's much easier to talk
about the act or the practice as I put
it than it is to decide who's a
journalist and um arguments about who is
a journalist tend to get
um U unproductive very quickly uh
primarily because what people are really
arguing about is status not
journalism um so if if if we want to
isolate well what's the journalistic
part part of that I just wrote about
this because I think it starts with this
is very relevant to Daisy it starts with
a particular kind of
claim when I say starts I mean the
origins of it way back in the mids of
time are with a particular kind of claim
and the claim goes like this I'm there
you're not let me tell you about
it that's the start of journalistic
authority
um so if we wanted to for example say
when did political journalism actually
begin like did it have a
birthday the birthday of political
journalism for us for the West Was when
the first guy managed to get into
Parliament and take down what was being
said there because at one time debates
in Parliament was illegal to report
debates in Parliament you had this weird
situation in in like early part of the
18th century and England where um people
who were part of parliament had free
speech within Parliament you could never
be prosecuted you could say King George
is an ass and nobody could touch you
because you had freedom of speech within
the halls of parliament if you said the
same thing outside you could be arrested
like in a day right so Parliament had
freedom of speech Parliament also had
information they had the budget they
knew what the King was up to they could
ask the Ministers of the king to come in
and tell Parliament what's going on so
Parliament at that stage had all the
rights that we associate with the
public and they called Parliament then
this is fascinating the people
indoors they were called the people
because they represented the people cuz
in their minds they were kind of like
representing the people compared to the
king okay so then there was the people
out ofd
doors who were they everybody else out
of doors there was no freedom of speech
there was no freedom of press and it was
a crime to tell people what went on in
Parliament okay so through a long series
of contestations and protests and heroic
actions by OB subversive people who are
basically that centuries
bloggers
uh eventually the right to report on
debates in Parliament was
secured so that person was the first P
political journalist why because he's
saying I'm there in Parliament inside
the building you're not because you're
living your life but I'm going to tell
you what they said right so that's
journalism so so the way I think about
it anybody who can make that kind of
claim and that claim has many
derivatives which I'll get to in a
second but anybody who can make that
kind of a claim is engaged in the
practice of Journalism so that's why we
have what you called earlier very
helpfully accidental journalists right
people who come upon a plane just landed
in the Hudson can you outside my window
can you believe that a plane just landed
in Hudson I'm there you're not let
me tell you about it right so that's
journalism now the the variations on
that on that claim involve like
different kinds of work so um I
interviewed that person you didn't let
me tell you what he said right I went
down to the hall of records and I looked
at the property re records and let me
tell you something Cheney owns seven
houses you know you you didn't and let
me tell you about it so so journalism is
is is is partly about that it's about
people finding stuff out or being able
to tell you something you're interested
in because of either where they are and
you're not or because of work they did
which you didn't
do and that relationship is is extremely
important so so with Daisy and and con
part of the problem is he was saying to
us and to his audiences as he went
around doing his show I was there
outside the gates of uh foxcon Apple's
Factory I saw 12 and 13 year olds going
in to work on Apple let me tell you
about it therefore he tried to claim the
sort of authority that a journalist has
and then it turns out he was there a
little bit
but he didn't see that and they weren't
13 and we can't actually rely on him so
it's a kind of counterfeit Authority
that he produced that is a problem
procedural note for folks sort of
squatting in the corners please feel
free to come on in there are more seats
in here come be comfortable we really
don't mind yeah you're not interrupting
anything yeah uh so one one question Jay
is is whether that's the only claim to
Authority right so one of the other
things the journalists end up doing is
saying okay well we heard this from the
people who were there maybe I wasn't
there maybe I wasn't in tumbuk tumale
but I spoke to someone there or maybe I
wasn't in tumbuk tumale but here are the
reports that came in to me and dhar
senagal which happens to be within near
Bureau is but you don't understand it so
let me explain to you what happened yeah
and that's another source of authority
that comes into play on all of this sure
what gets a little tricky in some of
this is that the truth is we we
journalism that simp says I was standing
by the Hudson there was a big thing in
the air it landed it looks like it is an
airplane you know eventually like that's
a limit to what it is what we really
want is then that person to sort of say
here's my legitimation for telling you
this now let me explain the larger thing
behind it here's the story behind it
here's what occurred with it yeah so so
let me just stop there because what I
said the origin was in this claim that's
all that's in my piece I call it it's
like the headwaters for for J listic
Authority right if you trace it all the
way back it's bubbling up right there
but Downstream lots of other things C so
what that becomes in a mature practice
of Journalism is what you were referring
to Ean which is sort of the art of
verification generally so
journalistic work in this blooming
buzzing media system we have is
identifiable because it is Prim
primarily concerned with verifiable
reports about what's going on uh as well
as as you said explanations that bring
Clarity to to public audiences as
opposed to specialized audiences um of
what's going on um now um it I think is
is a different
activity from let's say political
persuasion even though attempts at
political persuasion can be very
informative
right it's also a different activity
from standup
comedy even though standup comedy can
teach you a lot about the news right um
so I think you know we have we had to
make those kinds of distinctions if
we're serious about this this idea of
the practice of Journalism because not
everybody who's informing us about the
world is engaged in the practice of
Journalism which I think is a very
important
practice one of the things that came up
actually in a class yesterday as we were
talking about this was where that claim
to Authority comes from so one of these
ideas when when we're not talking about
here's the plane that just landed or
here's the Rebellion that's taking place
but the question is how do we unpack the
Greek financial crisis right that the
claim to Authority maybe here are the
things I know here's the context that I
can bring into this so one of my
students brought up the idea of Kora
where you have this giant question
answering site where basically the first
thing people say is here is why I have a
certain amount of believability
associated with this one of the things
that I would point to and again I'm
going to come back to your sort of
three-part model here is that the media
is changing so that we can sort of say
here are the people who are making the
claims of authority based first and
foremost on I was here and I spoke to
the Greek Prime Minister and here is
what he said today but there's now a
realm of reaction and commentary and so
on and so forth that's coming out of
this two-way media where what you may be
having now are assertions essentially
saying well so you asked I am a
macroeconomist who focuses on on
European debt and I'm able to tell you
now here's what comes into this right
I'm reluctant to call the first just
journalism the second just commentary to
me that seems a bit Sharp and a bit
Stark right I think this notion of claim
to Authority is very very helpful and I
think the notion of Journalism as
discipline of verification is helpful
but it also seems like you're talking
about the easy part of the iceberg
that's the stuff that's sort of above
the ground we can agree that it's
journalism if it's about an actuality
that someone is reporting and that
they're then able to authenticate and
verify but it seems like when we talk
about journalism and particularly when
we talk about the press and the role of
the press to inform the public
we're talking about a whole big iceberg
that lies below that true I'm
simplifying it too much yes I I and
that's what I've been complaining about
about everything lately so I'm going to
complain with you simplifying as well so
so how how do we go further with this
and and let me try to steer you back to
the question that I really want you to
answer which is what's the Press now
right is is the Press just the folks I
mean you you put out a very conservative
definition initially of the press you
know it's the the association of
newspaper
editors I would hope that the Press Now
isn't just the professional
verifiers but is some larger group of
people who are engaged in the
journalistic ACT which it sounds like
we're agreeing is more than just the
verification but is the
contextualization is the importance so
on and so forth it is some group of
people that is trying to talk about a
real event in the world a verifiable
event in the world and its importance
significance relevant so on and so forth
to a public somewhere who by the way are
now generally speaking back at the same
time yeah um I don't think we disagree
on this uh I I I didn't mean to suggest
that when you meet with the American
Society of newspaper editors you have
the entire press in the room it's just
it's more like a symbolic I assumed you
didn't that's why I wanted appro um but
let me let me go back to your point
about about the climate scientist or one
thing we left out of this picture um
that my friend Dave Winer um is the best
um is that because the media system now
puts the power to produce media in hands
of everybody as we all know um the
sources can go Direct that's how Dave
puts it which is a brilliant formulation
the sources can go direct so the people
who in the
past had to speak through journalists
because the media system was so
constricted and ended up trying to kind
of smuggle their knowledge into the
public sphere by being interviewed right
don't have to do that anymore the
sources can go direct and so if you are
an
authority uh on organizational behavior
or climate scientist or you know one of
of thousands of other
domains you now can contribute directly
to public knowledge now what what limits
you is not the media system anymore
that's what used to limit
you what limits you now is that the more
specialized your knowledge is the more
valuable it may be and the less likely
it is that you operate in the
vernacular you know what I
mean that
is your
language that you habitually use to tell
us what you know is less likely than
ever to be the public language that
everybody else uses now it's not to say
that there aren't Specialists who can't
communicate to the public there are
there a lot of them in fact that's sort
of what teaching is so there are a lot
of people who are good at that but um
that's the problem is and so yes it's to
way more complicated now because we have
the people formerly known as the
sources
can um inform us
directly
um what was the other part of your uh
question that you said you really want
oh the Press right so the Press I think
I think of the press as an
institution that is that is constantly
in motion like it's it's it's actually
very difficult to fix in any one place
or institution or thing or group of
people and what's so great about the
recent changes that we have seen since
that's say
95 is that I think they've brought the
press as an
institution much closer to the people so
that people now realize that they in a
way own the Press not that they own the
companies but they
own freedom of the press right freedom
of the press when when I started
teaching journalism in myu you're not
going to believe
this well you might believe this when I
started teaching journalism at myyu it
was
routine for journalism Deans to tell the
incoming class of Journalism students
journalism is the only profession that's
specifically mentioned in the First
Amendment they would say
this it's a bizarre thing to say what
was routinely taught it's bizarre for a
number of reasons first of all I've read
the first amendment I bet you have too I
have it does not say anything about
journalism ISM in it that word does not
appear in it okay so that's the first
problem but what were they saying when
they said that they were saying that we
professional journalists are not an
example of the press we are the Press
right we it is our thing like it's a
kostra right our thing between us and
that's like if you think about it what a
fantastic idea like what a fantastic
delusion what what human forces could
have created that kind of a
misreading among educated people who
think of the First Amendment as like
their religion right so it's their
religion and they have it wrong from the
first right so what's happened since
then is we don't teach nobody teaches
that anymore because everybody kind of
knows even professional journalists know
that freedom of the press doesn't mean
this group of people with press cards it
actually is is a public possession it
means everybody has the right to the
tools of the press right and so in that
sense the
institution is this fluid changing thing
that has to be continuously rediscovered
where it is so when courts say yeah
bloggers could be journalists they they
deserve protection under something like
a shield law right the Press is moving
it's being
redefined and that's what's great about
the present moment because for so long
these things were frozen and now they're
very much unfrozen and when when
something happens like that when when
something that's been set in a pattern
for a very long Ser period of time all
the sudden gets
disrupted people in our business have an
opportunity because everything's up for
grabs and now there's a chance to
rethink some old Concepts that's why I
started my blog press thing it's because
I I felt that because these things that
had been frozen for so long were now
unsettled and
uncertain now we could rethink a whole
bunch of stuff that had become
artificially Frozen so the membership of
the press is changing it's no longer the
secret fraternity I notice you're no
longer wearing your your pinky ring I
think you still have the the the tattoo
you never get any of these because
you're unusual as a as as a journalism
professor and that you're you're not
coming from the journalistic fraternity
but for those here in the fraternity you
can show the tattoos later over over
drinks but now we're suggesting that
we've sort of moved to a point where
this is a different space it's including
some bloggers some time what I want to
ask now is is how this changes the
public right so you put
forward a very interesting sort of
provocative suggestion more than a
decade ago about public journalism and
this notion that what you actually want
journalists to do is not just give the
facts but make it possible for the
public to participate in Civic processes
in one fashion or another right now
again we're talking about this major
shift that's going on and to review the
shift it's not just one class of people
not one professional tattooed class of
people who are reporting from now on and
there's a medium shift which suddenly
means that rather than being isolated
rather than sitting alone at my
breakfast table saying oh thank goodness
now I've learned what I should be doing
for the public there's this ability for
lateral connection there's this ability
to talk back there's ability to have
conversations going back andth
how does that notion how does that
notion of public journalism journalism
that makes it possible to be a Civic
actor how is that changeed by this
change that you're talking about well I
think there's a simple way of of
answering that which is that over time
in the one-way broadcast model media
system
that held
for let's say a century or
so what happened is that a relatively
active notion of the public
public kind of moved closer and closer
to the audience until we saw those two
things as the
same public is the
audience just inert and as I said right
so now what's happened is because the
underlying media system that we do this
with is changed again they are gradually
separated
again and we understand the public in
its original
meaning which
is people who affected by it talk about
the news and act on what they
learn that's what the public really is
it's not a bunch of people listening to
the political class and its
debates when that first
reporter uh took down what was said in
Parliament he wasn't doing it just for
fun his intention was to put it into the
newspapers and so that people in coffee
houses could read it and argue about
what the people in Parliament were
talking about um so that idea that it
and and this got lost in the era of
dominance by
professionals the idea that the Public's
job is not to be
informed that's only like the beginning
of it
The public's job is once
informed to
argue about the news to get outraged or
active right to take action and for all
the critique that we make which is good
about selectiv ISM and you know sort of
phony forms of action just the simple
fact that people think they should not
only know about what's going on but do
something about it that's a huge thing
so what's happening now is the the
public and and the audience are
separating right and a more active
notion of public is is returning and
part of what the that public does is
occasionally fills in in the role of
journalist but more often they're
they're arguing about the news they're
commenting on it they're sharing it
they're telling other people um what's
really important right everybody's
acting as an editor of everybody else
and that's the way journalism was
supposed to be from the beginning it's
like this subversive thing that belongs
to the public what is the alternative to
having a public the alternative is a
political class runs everything and and
the public sphere is people marveling at
the Majesty of the king as he floats by
you know so what I think it's really
nice about detaching public and audience
is that it helps us sort of think
through these changes going on in the
media shift in general right so that
second shift where we move from a
broadcast model to a lateral Model A a
two-way model of one fashion or another
you've got folks like Henry Jenkins
sitting here and essentially saying well
look you're seeing this in culture as
well yes you know even if you're
creating television even if you're
creating you know the ultimate audience
material you have some percentage of
people who are watching season two of
Game of Thrones instead of going wow
that's awfully bloody and you have some
other group of people say
and I'm going to write a political
parody of this or I'm going to figure
out how to extend this with fan culture
in one fashion or another and you might
think of this in some ways as sort of
moving into how other people are dealing
with journalistic environment some
percentage of people are watching and
perhaps first and foremost it's
entertaining perhaps other people are
watching and getting informed you're
then positing sort of multiple Pathways
to engagement right one is that you
argue with it and so in some ways what
we often you know think of as the
cesspits of the internet they comment
threads on public newspapers in many
ways are are actually what we should be
excited by it's people in one fashion or
another trying to figure out some way to
debate and engage with what's going on
another way that people debate and
engage with what's going on is they do
things they get active in a community
they get active in in a project one of
the very interesting things is that one
of the biggest things people do is they
amplify right so this is another thing
that's now changed within this media
environment that talking about right if
I'm affected by a story if I'm
interested in a story one of the
simplest ways that I can react to it
that I can sort of state I'm not just an
audience I'm a public is by saying and I
want you to pay attention to this too or
I want to pass this on or I somehow want
to gain attention to this right all of
which is wonderful the problem with it
is that the one thing that we haven't
really figured out how to change in all
of this is the supply of attention right
and so we're now at a point where rather
than a couple of TV stations a couple of
radio stations a paper in the morning
and a paper in the evening we now have
anyone we're interacting with in this
network at one level or another with the
possibility of making a legitimate claim
of our attention and so you also have
people crafting these claims to
attention in very interesting ways did
you know the Press which we don't trust
very much which has something under a
30% approval rating hasn't told you
anything about this horrible thing that
I found out about from a 30-minute
YouTube video which now I demand you pay
attention to because it is the human
rights abuse of our time now that
becomes a very complicated way to start
dealing with a a news and information
environment right when those claims are
being made not just by the professionals
but those claims are also now being made
by people who are joining the public by
getting into that business of amplifying
and yeah um huge problem
um that that's the kind of thing I would
I would like I would take years years to
try and puzzle it out um but let me let
me say a couple of things in reply
um one is that the the and Clay my
colleague clay shery who now has joined
me in journalism in NYU um really helps
here so he so he reminds us that for
most of the media system we have gone
from an economy of scarcity to an
economy of abundance right so it's OB
why that's the case because the tools
for producing media have been
distributed to the population at large
and the cost uh of production has
plunged and the media system is open so
all these economies of scarcity that
once sustain the media business are
evaporating however the new scarcity is
what you mentioned is a tension right so
that that is a huge a huge problem um
the other the other thing I would say
reply of that is that
um one of my one of my heroes in media
studies not not really well known
anymore is uh Raymond Williams who was a
sociologist um basically of the in the
Cold War era in the
UK um and Williams says in one of his
books he says this really profound thing
he's talking about mass communication
and he says look there are no masses
there are only ways of seeing people as
masses I'm going to say it again there
are no masses there are only ways of
seeing people as
masses so what does he mean there he
means that you can't actually go into a
house in Liverpool and find a mass man
and a mass woman that that's a that's a
fiction right because everybody is more
complicated than that whatever class
they may be but what is
real what has a kind of
historical reality to it is that the
ways of seeing people and reducing
people to masses those are real right so
the commercial formula is real right the
art of um attention flow that was
practiced let's say by TV programmers
who know how to keep you watching that's
real right um negative advertising that
doesn't have anything to do with the
truth but moves your emotions that's
real so this idea that the masses are
really a fiction but ways of seeing
people as masses are not is relevant
here why because even very quote unquote
well-intentioned people may practice
seeing others as
masses and if once we learn how to see
other people as masses
meaning um moving their emotions because
you need their emotions moved not
because they are open to that experience
right or
you're I I have the stimuli you are the
response right uh seeing people that way
reducing people that way in this very
highly
refracted uh form is itself a product of
the media age the media system that we
once had so when people for example say
um they say well we have to learn how to
get we have to get the
eyeballs think about that phrase like
what that phrase like we have to we we
couldn't get the eyeballs for our video
right what it's literally doing is it's
taking human beings and it's treating
one part of them which is their eyeballs
right as the thing right so what
the reason I love this phrase from
Williams so much Theon masses the only
ways of seeing people as masses is that
those ways of seeing actually migrated
out of the media industry and we all
know about them now and the fact that
some video maker who wants to draw
attention to his cause does that too
doesn't surprise me but I'm not going to
en Noble it because it's you
know an amateur you know or that or it's
somebody is well-intentioned because the
alternative to seeing people as masses
is to treat them as a
public so by the way I think you've uh
coined perhaps the worst pickup line
ever I have stimuli you have response I
try it in your favorite bar tonight see
how it does it for you uh in the
meantime I have my ways we in the me
that's not one of them in the meantime
we want to introduce you to uh to stop
being a mass and start being a public uh
and the way you can do this is by uh
arguing participating acting in one
fashion or another the action we would
ask you specifically is to step up to a
microphone uh we would ask you to be
pithy and uh preferably to remember that
questions tend to end with an
interrogative offer and upward tone uh
at the end of what would otherwise
perhaps be a
statement um so I just wanted to build
on on the Williams quote that you just
mentioned and I think the reason why I'm
asking this question is because you in
some of your comments mentioned you know
one of the things that's happening right
now is this opportunity to look at
conventions and things that been
solidified for a short period of time
and see them becoming unfixed and and so
I want to follow up on that a bit so the
idea is I think you could build on
Williams to say something like there is
no news there are only ways of seeing
certain kinds of stories as news and
historically that's happened in
different ways so going back to the 19th
century to build on this idea of you
know I was there you weren't I I'll tell
you a story about it I would I would
argue that at least in in some aspects
of American journalism at the end of the
19th century it was I was there I'm also
a very keen imaginative Observer and I'm
going to tell you a story um that will
be credible to you credible might not be
the right word for the 19th century but
will appear to you as news and so
actually the example from This American
Life that story of I was there and I'm
sort of mixing something together that's
part truth and part what I you know was
hearing from other people that might
actually be a sort of model that was
19th century journalism most famously
that's that's a model that um War
correspondence for the Cuban the Spanish
Cuban American war at times used and
were criticized for and I would argue as
part of the reason why we move corrupt
in Sinclair I mean so it's it's even
fairly recently and then in the 20th
century you moved to a paradigm where
it's not just I was there but I was
there I'm part of this institution and
set of standards that allows me to tell
a story that is credible because it has
two sides and because it's referring to
certain facts right and I think now some
of those things such as two sides of the
story are are moving away I think it's
very interesting I was reading recently
that NPR um put in its new ethics manual
that it's no longer requiring reporters
to tell both sides of the story it's
requiring reporters to adhere to the
truth whenever my blog so that's okay so
then so getting to the question so now
we're at this point where once again I
think what we're looking at is a shift
it's not just a shift in audience it's
also a shift in how we're looking at
news um and and so what do you see as
some of the new conventions that are not
yet conventions that are coming up yeah
that's that's a great question
um I'll tell you the one that interests
me the most um and and it is again it's
uh it's This American Life and um and I
reg glass but it doesn't involve the
daisy story
uh before the daisy episode I believe
the most downloaded episode of this
American life was the Giant pool of
money which was their one-hour explainer
on the roots of the financial
crisis and it it's a it's it's a great
it's like to me it's like one of the
most fantastic works of Journalism
ever um and I've listened to it you know
a number of times
and what's great about it is the way
that they put it together and and sort
of the nature of the rhetorical appeal
that they made because what they are
saying in that um in that documentary is
not we're Financial journalists and we
know this stuff so let us tell you what
happened or we got the best economists
in the world to explain to you what
happened and we got them right because
we went to MIT and we went to NYU which
actually has a better economics
Department than MIT uh
Chicago okay so they they didn't say
that but here's what they said they said
you know
what we were as confused as you were
about this we hear all this stuff about
subprime mortgages we can't believe that
our financial system is falling apart
because of Bad Mortgages it doesn't make
any sense so we're going to go out and
try to explain to
ourselves what went
on and we're going to find the smartest
people we can to explain it to us and
we're going to go and talk to people at
every level of the system from the guy
who sold the junk mortgages in Kansas
City to the local Banker who didn't care
whether they got repaid or not because
he was selling them to somebody else to
the guy in Wall Street who's packaging
these mortgages into these fancy
instruments to the global investor who's
buying them thinking this is a great
return we're going to talk to all of
those people and we're going to keep
talking to them until we understand
how this happened and once we understand
it as just regular people who have the
ability to ask questions we'll explain
it to you so that you can understand it
right so that's like that's not two
sides of the story that's not well
doesn't really matter if it happened or
not because it's a good tale and it's
not author uh institutional Authority
based you know we talk to the best
economists that's we were as confused as
you were so we went out and we
understood it ourselves so now we can
explain it to you right and I think
there's a lot in that form of Journalism
that we should be developing one of the
bits of that journalistic practice
that's sort of wonderful the people who
put that together have become the planet
money right and that spawn Planet Money
and they keep doing this one of the
things that they've said is that the
reporting tactic is to find someone
who's knowledgeable about a particular
topic and they say can you explain this
to me in terms that I can actually
understand right the person responds
then they say could you try that again
right and it often takes four or five
times through it but what's interesting
about it is two things emerge from it
the first is that unlike in the 19th
century model the Mike Daisy model the
words that you're getting is someone
telling you their experience and their
understanding of something it's getting
you much closer to an actuality the
actuality may be the interpretation of
someone who's part of the system but
that's that claimed authenticity the
claimed authenticity is not I am the
most knowledgeable person about
economics ever it is that I found this
person that is what they're saying yeah
so that has a rooting and a grounding to
it that's very interesting the second
thing that's fascinating about it that's
coming out of this is that one of the
other flaws of the sort of left right he
said she said you know well we'll have
to leave it at that CNN is this sense
that everything comes down to Left Right
which has become a massive societal
dysfunction for us and what's
interesting in many of these stories is
that it doesn't come down to the evil
banks have been systematically screwing
the homeowners and harming all of us or
if you read the w journal the evil
homeowners have been systematically
screwing the banks and ruining all of us
what it actually comes down to is here's
a very complicated system of actors all
acting within what they thought were
their best interests right and here's
this mess that it's ended up with and so
for me that's the hope for where the
storytelling gets is that it's not just
that it gets us Beyond sort of Civic
fictions and actualities it that gets us
into these systems of a great deal of
complexity Phil uh yeah one thing I'm
worried about is um the users uh the New
York Times used to make my basket for me
in the morning put all my news in there
and now I have to make my own basket I
got to go find the bloggers is more work
and I wonder if as I'm doing this I'm
building my own particular Taste of
basket and then somebody's building a
different one what you talk about left
and right are we all running off in
different directions like the the
universe everything flying apart from
everything else are we building fissures
because it's harder and you you can find
more of what you
want right so this is known as the echo
chamber
problem um sometimes I think that people
who complain uh about the echo chamber
are just listening to each
other get
it
um but I
think that complaint or
observation is partly a result of an
historical accident which is when you
had a media system with all these choke
points yeah people had to pay attention
to the same things not because they were
in love with the common culture right or
they all thought themselves part of the
same country but because there were only
three channels you know and
that's so that's the reality right and
they all pretty much did the same thing
so that was it was just a result of the
media system at the time and we
shouldn't romanticize it what we also
should say but maybe even though this
was an historical accident something is
lost right I think that's a very valid
point and I think it's probably true
something was lost when we moved to the
world of 400 channels and and thousands
of people the other thing that is really
important for people in in the
university to to to understand is that
we really have to look
carefully at the people in these Echo
Chambers
and look at their behavior to know
whether this argument is
true um for example is it true that the
Denis of the most right-wing political
blogs don't know anything about the
Denis of the most left-wing blogs I bet
you it's not true in fact I bet you the
people who know the most about the left
wi blogs are the people at the extreme
right-wing blogs and there are by the
way some studies that show that okay so
I don't think we should assume we know
sort of from this
deductive way of of approaching the
question it's really an inductive
question of let's find out whether the
people populating these so-called e Echo
Chambers know less or more about the
other Echo Chambers and or not so I I
think it's a complicated sort of
question so I I take Echo Chambers more
seriously than you do I actually think
this is is one of the problems that we
do have to address in a fairly serious
way and I think in some ways reducing it
to left and right oversimplifies the
problem here here's how I would rather
frame
it we head back to a broadcast era and
you have media that's mostly controlled
by a curator that curator is an editor
maybe the curator is an anchor the
curator is someone essentially saying
here's your basket here's what you need
to to pay attention to today there are
lots of flaws with that model we can
certainly go and and find systematic
biases and distortions but it is
interesting that someone is taking on
what is to a certain extent a Civic role
of saying I'm going to keep you
interested and I'm also going to try to
give you some aspect of variety we then
shift paradigms we move into much more
of a search Paradigm right you don't
care very much about Japanese Sumo I do
and so I get to look up the website
where I can get my Sumo Reserve for
every B show and you don't have to worry
about it and we're in a world of much
more choice because you can worry about
what you want to worry about and I worry
about my what I want to worry about and
that's where the eoch chamber argument
emerges the problem with that is that we
start having problems with Discovery
function there might be something over
in what I'm reading that you really want
to find out about and so we move to
social know you and I are in the same
social network and so I find something
wonderful about Japanese Sumo that
actually you really need to know which
is great you found found it via social
but we tend to be birds of a feather who
flock together and our social network
gives us information from some people
and not from other people and so for me
what I'm now waiting for is sort of that
next step it's something that has some
of the same concerns of curation of
making sure that we're getting a lot of
ideas from a lot of different places
right that takes advantage of this new
medium and our ability to talk back to
it and to share and to spread but in
some ways takes very seriously this
notion that I'm a public and that I'm
not an audience and take seriously this
notion that here are things that I'm
discovering in my own searching and my
own social that you might need to know
and that might be a way to go further I
don't think we're there yet I think
we're pretty far from having the
Serendipity engine that takes what's
good about those other three methods and
getting us there but I think it's an
interesting solution to something that I
actually see as a real problem so how do
you see somebody like um Mar a brain
picker in in that
model in what specific sense well I mean
here's somebody who's um curating from
across the web yep all kinds of things
that I didn't ask for right but she's
very popular yeah she's not she's not an
isolated yeah specialist person she's
somebody that has building up a general
audience I think one of the things
that's starting to emerge are curators
who are really good at it are really
good at it and are really going after
that Serendipity function which is
starting to be missing within the
ecosystem yeah see I think there what
you want in that curator for let's say
the public sphere which is the part I'm
tend to be most concerned about even
though it's the same problem basically
in the cultural sphere is you want
somebody who's um attentive to
data um aware of what people quote
unquote want like what what tends to get
them excited but
also aware of that this Serendipity
thing is also something people want
right like what it's kind of paradox
when you say well what what would you
like and you say surprise me right what
you're really saying is I don't know
what I want right so surprise me right
so it's partly that and then there's
also got to be certain things everybody
has to know right uh and we need our
curators to kind of like use their
judgment about that but yeah it's we I
think we're we're going to we're moving
towards a solution to this problem but
it's not going to be an echo chamber and
it's not going to be the voice of god so
let's not get lost in Serendipity let's
go we're going to get lost because I'm
going to follow up on that question
which is about curation and as a
consumer of news I'm just tired of
having to look everywhere at everything
and read tweets and and look at Facebook
and look at this and look at that I can
go to super supermarket and see a wall
of cereals and I can pick one off the
shelf and I can know how much fiber is
in it and I can know whatever so I want
I don't want to know necessarily right
or left about my curator I want to know
a lot more I want all the nutritional
label I can get on these sources can I
get
that I'm working on it uh and more to
the point you know a number of the folks
in this room are working on it um th
this is one of the big project s that we
took on at Center for civic media uh and
we started sort of from the the same
basic notion which is to say attention's
a scarce commodity there's only so many
places that we can look it's not
necessarily that I want it even balance
between leftwing and right-wing news but
maybe I do want some sense that I'm
getting some views from different parts
of the globe maybe I want a sense that
I'm getting some views for people who
have different views different
perspectives so on and so forth maybe I
want to make sure that I'm getting
getting some science versus some health
so on and so forth the first way to do
this is to think about this from a
nutritional information perspective and
the first way that you have to do this
is you have to break apart what a
nutrition information label is the first
thing that a label is is it's a
statement of contents these are things
that are in this and and yes you could
figure it out by flipping through the
whole paper and saying oh interestingly
enough 12% of what I read was Obama but
it's really helpful to have that sort of
show up very early on and say Here's the
geographic distribution here's the topic
distribution so on and so forth the
second thing nutrition information label
says is here's how much of it you should
eat and I don't want to do that I
actually think it's very important to
split the descriptive and the normative
I think sitting there and essentially
saying bad New York Times you've only
got 20% international news today the
recommended daily allowance is 25 is
probably a very very poor idea but I do
think going and saying
you know here is what you're
consistently getting from the sources
that you're going to now where I think
we really want to go over time is to get
Beyond label reading and get to
something that's much closer to the
Quantified Self movement so some number
of people in this room are carrying in
their pocket shiny little pedometers uh
fitbits uh this is a fairly popular
thing at the MIT media lab and their
pedometers that measure your steps per
day the floors you climb they put it
into your computer if you're good about
you can also add in how much food you've
eaten and sort of get a general sense of
your physical activity over the day and
what it gives you is this sort of
dashboard on certain aspects of your
health and one of the questions becomes
to the extent that we all start becoming
digital consumers it seems reasonable
that we can start doing this for what
we're consuming into our heads as well
it's not hard to set something up that
essentially says here are all the web
pages that I read that's very easy to do
getting from that to sort of generalize
and say oh actually I've spent 45% of my
time today reading about Sumo and only
5% reading about uh the presidential
election and then looking at that and
saying maybe I want to change my
behavior that's a much harder problem
but that's one of the things that we're
working on here right now is both sort
of building those systems first around
being able to put those descriptive but
not normative labels on media and then
making it possible to sort of
internalize it to the point where you
can then look at your diet and say my
gosh that's a lot of Bieber I'm going to
crank that down a little bit and at that
point we could then possibly say to you
the people around you are reading
something different or really smart
people in Nigeria reading something
different or people who are highly
knowledgeable about journalism or about
health or something else are reading
this instead and to me that's where some
of the Serendipity Solutions came from I
I I would like to see a different
approach I like that approach I I think
I love your question I would like to see
approach sort of like this where I can
sign up for for what do I want to be an
informed person
about and I can measure how I'm doing
through some sort of
quiz and then I can adjust my
information diet based on the competence
I want to reach right so I want to say
to my news system I want keep me
informed about this okay and rather than
just get a diet of news aimless news
stories about that I have an actual way
to know can we gamify can we give you
badges I you you use that word I did not
I carefully avoided that word but you
all right but anyway that's the system I
want
sir um on the previous question I'm one
of the people who fact check the fact
Checkers and who gather information on
various topics around the world and let
other people know my job is how to get
education to to a billion children and
end poverty and so that's the primary
focus of my news Gathering now actually
I'd like to ask you questions about
roughly half of what you said but I
won't we appreciate
that uh I want to observe that science
has a partial answer to the question of
Journalism which is that it isn't what
you think you know it's whether you have
the right
questions but my actual question to you
is I believe I I I'm kind of hoping I
misunderstood you I believe you said
something about mass media creating this
notion of people as
masses except that as far as I can tell
this is prehistoric and simply comes out
of
tribalism is that right because there's
an old zen Coan which I can uh simplify
in a sense as there are two kinds of
people in this world those who divide
everybody into two kinds US versus them
and those who
don't well tribalism is important mean
that the and the history of it is is uh
is is certainly relevant to this
discussion because tribalism is like you
said birds of a feather flock together
the the origins of modern
journalism are very tied up with the
origins of something else which is the
nation state itself
but I'm asking
about
Tre yeah it's probably yeah that's right
it's probably
um some part of human nature some way
Jay specifically putting it on mass
media and I think if the question is did
the notion of the mass proceed mass
media no I don't think I said that no no
no but okay so let's take a question
over here so Jay I really lik um your
description of the historical relations
which characterize journalism as a
profession I'm there you are not um and
the other ways that primitive journalism
Justified itself uh and in print the
curatorial powers of a newspaper editor
were driven by practical considerations
only so many pages you have available
only so much newsprint it's the result
of a historical accident suppose clay
and the others are right and the
production scarcity is over and the new
relevant scarcity is attention as you
two were just discussing about Maria
brainpicker and so forth how does the
professionalization of an attention
curator change in terms of training
accreditation expertise and daily
practice is it a different sort of
scarcity and basically the same
professionalization system that produces
attention curators or is there a more
fundamental shift in how these new
curators of information understand and
legitimize
themselves Chris by the way just came
out of a session that we were having
down at Center for civic media about
questions so we just spent two hours
talking about what it means to have a
good question and how you would try to
get people to write better questions
over time and praise good questions and
you know uh complain about other
questions so I I just want to give the
backdrop to that that that particular
extremely fine question so I think what
you're asking Chris is is that your name
Chris yeah uh is sort of in a world of
where attention is the
scarcity what what does a good curator
do like what what's the code of ethics
what what are the what what is the
practice based
on and I haven't really thought a lot
about that but I think there's are are a
few starting
points one of them is you respect
people's
time that's probably the most important
one you respect people's time you don't
waste their
time and you help them save time time
the I often tell my students the
simplest way to create value in
journalism is to save the user
time um so that's number one
secondly good
curators are
good not because they're world's
greatest Authority or because they've
been certified by
somebody but because they are thems El
richly
interactive with the people they are
curating for so that would be the second
thing respect the user's time and
interact with the users so you know who
you're curating for
right that person in other words has to
be very
two-way um
third is we
can use data to help us
so because we have good data about what
people actually use that we're putting
out we have to learn how to read that
data without becoming enslaved to it
right so smart uses of the data help us
be better
curators um and I think also that
um the people who are really good at
this Maria is a good example but there
are others have this latent thing that
actually has been part of Journalism
since there was a an occupation of
Journalism which is a very very strong
curiosity about stuff like they just
like to know weird stuff do you know
anybody like that you know they never
never met anyone like that they just
love they just love to know weird stuff
and and and they're much more likely to
ask a question about you than they are
to tell you what they
think because they they can sense an
opportunity to like satisfy their
curiosity so that that' be sort of where
I where I would start
um but I think we could probably get a
better answer by looking at the people
who are really good at it and studying
them you know and breaking down what
they do one reminder in all of this
might be that when we talk about the
profession of Journalism we tend to
focus a great great deal on the man or
woman with the pad and camera at the
scene of an event yeah taking down the
notes and coming back and writing up the
story and and in many cases we actually
want to think about the curation aspect
of this as well what goes in what gets
cut what gets killed what gets page one
how it gets prioritized yeah that's been
part of a journalistic profession right
and in the same way that that's now
moving into proam and and citizen models
it's possible to commit an act of
curation much as it's possible to commit
an act of Journalism and that may
actually happen much more often than the
acts of Journalism editors have always
been the behind the scenes journalists
that matter as much as the person with
the with the pen but that function has
been
democratized please thank you so I think
the previous question assumed a scarcity
of attention and my question somewhat
questions that assumption and my
question is is there competition between
the millions of people who practice
journalism and professional journalists
and is that competition healthy and if
so who
wins um well there there is competition
in in certain ways yeah I think that I
think it's fair to say that
um do you start your day with uh with a
news site you know to get to kind of
reorient yourself to the public world or
do you start your Day by looking at your
favorite blogger or curation site or do
you start your day by looking at what
your friends are recommending you know
that's that's a
competition um who to listen to for post
debate analysis you know is a comp it's
a competition you can you can turn to
the professional pundits right or you
can look at what the chatter is in in
social media so I think that's actually
happening it's
real and it's a good thing uh because th
those things shouldn't be
closed uh activities what we don't need
is um I'm a journalist you're
not that doesn't help
us competition isn't Just Between the
journalists it's between journalists and
advertisers it's between journalists and
entertainers it's between Citizen
curators and journalists I mean I think
what's so hard about the competition in
some ways is that I I I do think
attention is scarce I think at a certain
point you can only subdivide the hours
of the day so many time and and so what
you're choosing to pay attention to you
have an entire industry essentially
dedicated to trying to figure out how to
capture and then sell your attention
that's what advertising is basically and
so that's always been a competition it's
been sort of an interesting symbiotic
relationship historically with
entertainment
and with news media but that's moved
into a much more competitive space and
now I think there's a competitive space
between the professionals the amateurs
instead of everyone engaged in that
please um one of the uh claims that
journalists have also made is that we're
going to tell you what is important in
addition and that maybe and in the old
days you would see on the front page
what was the the stories you needed to
know about to be an informed citizen on
your way of a comics on your way of a
classified ads on the way to all the
other things that you probably actually
bought the paper for and now we have
this unbundling and this scarcity of
attention and people
are most people most of the time would
rather read about Justin Bieber or watch
cat videos instead of becoming informed
members of the public and how do what
takes over that role of of making sure
that people check their their
nutritionally
right that's a question I've been asked
like 400 times in one way or another
which doesn't mean it's a bad question
it means it's a very important question
and the first 200 times I I was asked
that I had a really crappy answer um so
I figured I should I should think about
this um and here's the best answer I
have for you it's true that at one
time we had this group of people we
could call them Priestly if we wanted to
or we could just say they're
professional
who were able to say to us um this is
what's important and it was hard to
generate alternatives to that okay so
now we're in this much more open system
where this is a good way of thinking
about that competition there's everybody
trying to say to you this is what's
important to you now right everybody
from activists to journalists to friends
to advertisers to spectacle makers right
um and so h so what happens to that to
that function so I think what we really
want is not somebody who can say to
us um this is
important what we want is somebody who
can say to us this is important who we
trust and believe right and in order
for journalists to play that
role so that when they say you're not
paying attention to this you're actually
more interested in your video game or
your pop star or your latest movie um
but you should what we
want is for that recommendation to
actually stick right we want people who
can say that who are
persuasive and in order for those people
to be persuasive when they say you're
not paying attention to this but you
should because this is really important
important they need to understand us
they need to be in interaction with us
they need to be accessible in some way
we have to be able to talk to them right
we have to be able to reach them Gloria
bourger who just wrote an un
unbelievably moronic column in CNN about
how the failure of healthc care is both
parties fault and all this this is
somebody who I need to reach if I'm ever
going to listen to her I have have to be
able to talk to this person if I'm ever
going to listen to anything she says
again and so I think for the people who
would fill that role of saying this is
really important and you need to pay
attention to it those people have to
become much more available interactive
honest two-way reachable genuine and
they have to get out of there prly roll
otherwise that function is just going to
disappear please hi uh I'm I've been in
the media business my entire career and
I don't I don't really care about
journalists anymore than I care about
plumbers um they're important obviously
but um but I care very much about uh
sources of good Civic information that I
can get efficiently and so forth my
question is this could the source and
and IT addresses the previous guys
question as well uh could the source of
good information
be a new kind of political
party based on Modern Information
Technology governed through modern
technology and basically based on the
premise of efficiently delivering
valuable Civic information most of which
by the way is pretty boring um to
Citizens so that they can conduct
themselves in their civic life which is
a very small portion of their life
efficiently MH yeah that's it's a very
good point um if you look at um the
growth of the federal government uh what
you find in the 20th century is that
under pressure from essentially the
Progressive Movement government began to
become a recorder and reporter of
reality so all these things that we make
news from now like Labor Statistics that
tell us the unemployment rate right um
Commerce Department's measurement of
economic
output uh or even something as simple as
the number of people who are minors or
somebody who are engaged in this area of
the economy or that that whole apparatus
which we take for granted was created by
the federal government in order that
people could understand what was going
on so we already have a system where
government is itself a huge producer of
Civic information that helps people
understand what's going on and more and
more of that data now is being put
online and that's a huge movement that
we haven't talked about at all the
government 2.0 transparency movement
right which is very related to this
question and if you can find out
yourself uh about those earmarked
Appropriations that Congress approved
you don't necessarily need a
professional journalist down there
researching all the ear marks if you can
look them up so part of the functions of
Journalism can actually be kind of
transferred to data Information Services
we but of course we have to trust the
people who are producing those things
political parties
could possibly become sources of
reliable information not the political
parties we
have um they're not going to do it uh
but it's naive to think that all of the
information we need to figure out what's
happening in our world comes from
journalists journalists themselves are
working with information that's produced
by other institutions they're parasitic
on those other
institutions but I I I'm going to argue
perhaps the opposite here um which is
that I I think trust is not the main
constraint on all of this so I I'm
putting together a conference right now
and the title of it is the story and the
algorithm and the reason this came up is
that a lot of the people who are sort of
working in this space are looking at
some of these transparency efforts and
some of these efforts to do a new form
of Journalism through aggregating data
probably the best known of this is a
project called every block uh where you
have uh a brilliant technologist in
Chicago essentially saying can we take
all the information that comes out for
the city of Chicago can we lay it on a
map and can we make it possible for you
to find out everything you would need to
know about what was going on in your
neighborhood what you were directly
affected by right it's a lovely idea in
the sense that it's taking advantage of
this transparent information it's
finding ways to make it real to you
because it's on the map you can find it
ex exactly where you are exactly what
happened with the liquor store getting a
license or the robbery on the corner
it's not done very well as a
journalistic project right and it turns
out that there's a big difference
between datas and story and most of us
don't deal very well with data even if
we get a large data set we may need to
do a lot of work before that data set
makes any sense for us right and even if
we find random correlations in that data
set getting to the point where we
actually understand what's the narrative
behind it and then particularly getting
point where we actually care about it
seems to be very very complicated right
and so my feeling is in some ways I I I
think your suggestion is is very much in
line with sort of the Zeitgeist of of
maybe the last half decade or so and I
think it's absolutely the right
direction and I think we're now sort of
starting to bump into some of the limits
of it where this is working really
powerfully is where transparency efforts
whether they're government or whether
you know theoretically coming from a
political party um is starting to meet
the ability of someone to pull stories
from it and I don't necessarily mean
stories in the sense of fables I mean
stories in the sense of being able to
tell a story through the data and start
explaining something that was perhaps
hard to explain previously right so
where do the experts in data meet the
experts in narrative where do this where
do they come together you had a follow I
just
want a lot of this conversation has been
about
NPR and I have heard a statistic that
people who contribute to
NPR 9% of
V it's an interesting statistic and uh
so so my point is uh if a group of
Voters fund the source of
information and call it a political
party that's what I'm
talking it's a nice clarification thank
you let's go over here um a question
which I guess kind of pertains to the
title of of the event um adapting
journalism to the web the question is do
you generally in the grand scheme of
things think that journalism has really
been adapted to the web um my theory is
that this really hasn't happened on a
couple of levels I mean what you're
talking about here for example data
journalism I think it's interesting is
you know the most high-profile story
there was still Wikileaks and originally
they worked with the original press so
Spiegel New York Times Guardian to get
the information out um you also
mentioned before that you know how do
you start your mornings you know I don't
traditionally read the newspaper but you
know even before I roll out of bed you
know I read my Twitter feeds um but then
again most of those links go back to the
original press New York Times Guardian
spegel side you know Austrian newspapers
things like that and um the third
observation is that I think a lot of uh
journalism these days that you can find
on the web actually isn't really adapted
to the web because one of the things
that personally drives me insane is that
you know when I find an article and it
says and you know according to Euro
stats that statistics so and so um
that's what's happening that's the
context and you know and there's no
freaking link to get back to the source
um because the people who write it yeah
generally you still think about you know
the print where you know you can't have
a hyperlink um so I'm really wondering
how far has journalism been adapted and
if so what do you think really needs to
happen on a practice level not not on a
consumption level um for it to to Really
adapt and use the possibilities of the
web right well there's a reason for that
there's a reason why that ation which I
share um is still there and the reason
is that when the major news
operations
first created their sites which was
around 95
96 the first thing they thought of to do
with
them was to repurpose their
content um and you could understand why
they did that right they had already
made the print newspaper it was already
in a digital form form because they had
uh you know they used computers to make
the print newspaper so they basically
dumped
their print product online and it it
made sense in a way economically but it
had it had one huge problem which was
when you start that way you don't get
around to
asking wait a minute what's the web good
at what is it really able to do
because it actually is a very flexible
platform and if what you want to do is
dump data on it from a prior platform
the web says okay yeah sure we can do
that I mean if that's what you really
want to do we can do that right and so
what happened was that the question wait
a minute what's the web really good at
for
journalism didn't get asked until maybe
8 n years after these news organizations
started their sites and their systems
aren't so I I agree with you that we are
actually
very uh
poor in models and inspiration and
adapting journalism to the web those who
have probably made the most progress are
the born and the web news organizations
you know and that's why there's such a
split between the old media and the new
the new media never had this problem of
repurposing content um which was such a
huge factor in uh in in those
sites so I think we're on our our last
two questions here let take a quick
question here and then we'll let David
now what what you just said is an
example of what I meant earlier about
asking the right
questions and that's the entire topic of
the book The innovator's Dilemma yeah
where you repurpose what you already do
but you don't ask the question about
what comes next yeah but the pre
previous question was who's good at
taking data and turning it into a story
and I don't have the answer CU there
isn't such a thing but an answer is gap
minders which uh recently was featured
on TED Talks where they take the data
and they use everything in Edward tufty
on visualizing quantitative information
and they do four and five dimensional
Graphics that tell you what's really
going on country by country across the
entire world and a hundreds of different
measures of what's important what's
challenging about hun rosling's project
is that you're dealing with someone who
has 40 Years of development economics
and health experience working with his
son who's been a visualization and
graphic designer for 20 years so they
took the platform they brought it over
to Google and everyone sort of said well
this is great now we have Gap minder for
everything and actually very little has
sort of come out on Gap minor because it
turns out that what you actually need is
the incredibly deep expertise with the
data plus the close relationship with
someone with a tool so it's it's a bit
of a high bar to set I think anyone
who's looked at Han's work will happily
agree that that's pretty much what we
all aspire to what's a little tricky is
that we're also dealing with this in an
environment where it's very very
difficult to make the finances work in
this field and so one of the questions
becomes how do we get to a world where
perhaps we get better at bringing the
people who are the scientists who have
that very deep understanding of the data
together with the people who can do the
storytelling and I think that's what I
wanted to get at we can actually ask the
question now great and some of us will
get some of us who are motivated will
get answers and do more one just one
thing on this before we before we wrap
up what if maybe we're going about this
the the wrong way what if we compensated
and rewarded and um
glamorized journalists and news
organizations by how much their users
learned of the world you're back to the
quizzes yeah yeah like and the badges
yeah if we did it that way I bet you
some of these things would start to
happen right like you you get promoted
you get your prize if the users actually
learned a lot more about how things work
in this world mat Matt stempek who's in
the audience somewhere probably
frantically blogging this talk and he's
now trying to blog while I'm talking
about him has been sketching out a game
which is basically it's the game of Risk
but it's updated for a news age and you
only get to invade Kamchatka if you read
enough about Kamchatka that you can
answer the questions about kamaka so if
you want to win this sort of Facebook
game of Risk against everybody body else
you have to be sufficiently
knowledgeable about the continents that
my family will test drive this game I a
14-year-old and a 10-year-old and I
would love for them to know Matt I know
you're down to two hours of sleep at
night we'd like you to take it down to
one so there are complaints of
colonialism that game ah I'll put let
let's put that on the microphone he said
there are complaints about colonialism
with that game
model I I I think defending the Cold War
view of risk is probably going to be a
hard thing for me to do an academic
stage I think the joke of it is that if
you're going to play a game it's not a
bad game to sort of think about what a
world map looks like you could do that
in world of workcraft there enough
information but you you have a certain
self- selected audience true d uh I
don't want to make prolong the day and I
this has been a productive and very
interesting session I I think the
questions from the audience were
particularly helpful and interesting but
I I I want to express one sort of
perspective and ask Jay especially to
respond to it I guess I was surprised
Jay that a that a teacher of Journalism
would show such easy dismissive uh uh
such an easy dismissive attitude toward
the quote expert although I understand
where it's coming from and I had the but
more than that the notion that that's
all a journalist is or that that's
primarily what a journalist is seems to
me problematic so what surprised me
about the whole conversation essentially
was how optimistic it is how happy you
seem to be uh and I don't mean that
there isn't reason for optimism and
great excitement about what these uh new
systems and new technologies and so
forth are making available to us but I
think that most people who pay attention
to the news and public affairs who have
been alive for more than 15 years adults
for more than 15 years might certainly
feel that in in that in today's
environment we are we may be data rich
and and noise rich but but we're not
really uh uh at we're not really we have
haven't really been enriched at all in
in terms of our understanding of public
affairs and it's even possible to make
very powerful arguments that the decline
of the so-called professional journalist
has had catastrophic in at least
immediate consequences the stuff that
I'm sure you know better than I do Jay
The Disappearance of investigative
journalism the absolute gutting of cbs's
news's distinguished foreign foreign
bureaus the the The Disappearance of so
many foreign bureaus from newspapers
around around the country
uh we're almost to the point now where
there's only one serious newspaper in
the United States uh and it seems to me
that it would it would please me if you
would address some of the difficulties
that this remarkable transition has
offered and and and perhaps talk more uh
directly about about the extent to which
one way to think about a journalist is
not as an expert or or someone who's
handing down uh um obiter dicta from on
high but rather as a mediator a trained
intell ENT mediator who goes and studies
or or or does a form of study of
particular topics that ordinary citizens
don't have the time to do and reports
back to them to help them that's the
idea of Journalism that I was aware of
when I was in journalism school that's
the idea of Journalism that sort of
inspired generations of people to think
that being a journalist was a was a was
a noble profession and I'm disturbed by
the extent to which I I understand that
idea of Journalism has been under attack
and that in many ways it was a fiction
just as the fiction of objectivity is a
fiction but an incredibly valuable one
just because a pure objectivity is
impossible doesn't mean you can't try to
be fair but especially right-wing media
and right-wing politicians have spent so
much time over the last 15 years arguing
that the mainstream media is completely
biased that trust in what the media says
has broken down what I'm wondering about
is what whether or not there often also
haven't been terrible losses involved in
these advances and whether you would
would at least address them briefly
before we close mhm sure um well it's
true there's there's a uh there's a
crisis of uh employment in professional
journalism and uh we see it in the the
thinning out of of Staff we see it in
the Lost eyes on power in places like
state capitals City
Halls uh we see it in um this the
thinness of the product if you pick up a
metropolitan newspaper most places in
this country there's very little in it
you know um you're talking about
organizations now that are perhaps
capable of producing maybe five six
stories a day and that that's all that
that they can do and so there there has
been a a huge loss of
capacity um in uh mainstream journalism
and the newsrooms that were are
powerfully associated with it um one of
the reasons I didn't talk about it that
much is that the forces that are
creating those
losses are so large and Global and
undeniable that to solve that problem
it's almost like you you would have to
say something really sarcastic and and
even more annoying than I've been which
is is what are you going to do uninvent
the internet because that's what you
would have to do to bring that situation
back the problem of how do you
economically
support those reporters those boots on
the ground that have been lost to these
changes is right now an unsolved problem
of course yeah but one one way to sort
of point up this disagreement or this
this this reservation I have about the
tone of the discussion is to say why
does it follow from that that we should
denigrate what a journalist is in other
words it seems I don't agree that I'm
denigrating seems to me it seems to me
that we were reducing professional
journalists to irrelevancy in this
discussion that we were essentially
saying nobody really needs these kinds
of mediators anymore mostly they
belonged to elitist Publications that
handed down information to the stupid
masses and and the fact that we're now
in an environment where we can look at
sumo wrestling as much as we want and
log on only to those people with whose
opinions we agree that that circumstance
is somehow Superior it doesn't David I
don't I don't think either person on the
stage was making that argument I don't
mean I don't mean to say that making AR
but I do mean that was a an implication
of the extent to which we're we've we've
have someone here who's who's spent 10
years in conversations this last decade
over and over and over again that sort
of start with the crisis right and in
many ways Jay sort of gave a rough
outline of the crisis and not just the
crisis but the causes of the crisis but
what you have here and who you were by
the way wise enough to invite was
someone who is very much engaged with
trying to figure out how you make
journalism a viable survivable
professional field in this decade way
that was my question I mean I AB
absolutely agree and listen I I mean I
have the as Jay knows I mean have the
tremendous admiration for the work that
he does what I was talking about the
tone of our conversation the direction
it had gone it seemed to me that it was
an unintended consequence because I know
everybody in fact I know you respect
journalists too but it does seem to me
that it would be valuable to talk about
the advantages and and and professional
seriousness of the old ideal of
Journalism and ask whether or not it's
valuable to transfer those qualities
onto the web well perhaps the reason
you're you're sensing this David is that
I do have a belief which I haven't I
didn't articulate here
today that at some point in in its
Evolution probably midcentury 20th
century professional
journalism went arai in some way I
believe that I don't think most people
who spent their careers in it believe
that this is a point of tension and
disagreement between me and a lot of
people I think something happened partly
in the development of what they call
objectivity not that there's something
necessarily bad about objectivity about
um part in in in in the ways that
journalists compromise with the
advertisers um partly had to do with the
media system and how constricted it was
but in somewhere in there rising to a
peak somewhere in the late
70s a a missing element in professional
journalism started to loom larger than
all the good things that were also in
professional journalism and I haven't
been able to trace it back to to its
source it's something that that we could
talk about for quite a long time but I I
do think that that in some way or
another the it's like the foundation
was wrongly
constructed and the longer that thing
went on the the worst it
got uh and I think you you can see this
in um things like trust
figures the peak of trust in the news
media is like 1976 and then it goes down
from there with a real acceleration
after 2000 and during that period from
1976 to let's say
2006 one of the strange things about
that period is that journalists were
becoming during that time more
educated more likely to go to journalism
School more
um uh professional standard
were on the rise during that
time and the journalist as a cultural
figure was
becoming um more respected and it became
more of a respectable occupation more
desirable occupation so that you had
Elites that used to go into law and
Banking and politics would also start
going into journalism so so how can it
be that you have more educated people
more well-trained Rising professional
stand there's Rising cultural
status at the same time that you have
declining
trust that to me that's a puzzle right I
call it the trust Puzzler in journalism
and I don't I don't know the answer to
that question but I think I start I gave
you the start of the answer which is
that there was something arai in
professional journalism
now I teach people who want to be
journalists
that's all I teach we don't have a PhD
program at NYU we don't educate public
relations people we don't educate people
to go into entertainment the only people
I see in my classes are people who want
to be
journalists now I am not so perverse as
to spend 25 years of my life educating
those people because I hate journalism
okay so I want them to improve
journalism I believe the profession of
journalist and and the main reason I
believe in it is that you need some
people who do all these things fulltime
you need people fulltime on the case of
monitoring power not because they're the
only ones who can monitor power but
because the full-time people can do
something that the part-time people
cannot you need somebody fulltime on
understanding the financial industry
because it's a complicated thing and
they are not the only ones but we okay
okay so I want there to be those people
and I want to be part of the figuring
out how they can have careers because I
want my students to get jobs because if
my students don't get jobs I won't have
any students if I don't have any if I
don't have any students you know now
this really good life that I have will
just disappear so so so I have every
motivation to continue the project of
professional journalism but I am also
obligated to look get it as a Critic and
say Here's what's wrong with this
picture and very often when I do that uh
I just wrote about this the other day
the answer I get back is well what would
you know you've never worked as a
journalist which is true you know um
because I don't really have a career as
a journalist but if you think about it
that's kind of an odd thing for
journalist to say isn't it I mean here
you have all these people who write
reviews of plays but they've never been
play rights right they report on major
league baseball but they couldn't make
their high school team you know they are
out there reporting about Wall Street
but they've never run a financial firm
right and they're saying to me what
would you know you've never been a Jour
you know it's a little bit a little bit
odd um however I not only do I believe
in the profession of Journalism but I
think it's really important that at a
certain time it tried to professionalize
itself because what happens when a group
of workers try to professionalize
themselves is yes they try to claim
status they try to claim exclusive
rights there's all these negative things
about it but there's a very positive
thing about it which is the only way you
can claim that what you do as a
profession is that you have put at the
heart of it public service right that's
what a profession is because there is no
such thing as a profession that's just
there for the good of the profession
right a profession is based on a notion
of public service and nothing is more
valuable in journalism than that
in the spirit of my best uh CNN
moderator I'm going to say and we'll
have to leave it at that so thank you
everyone for being here thanks for being
part of the conversation